I'm on Marylebone Road in London the
building behind me is now the landmark
hotel but for many years it was a
headquarters of British Rail the
government organization that ran every
one of the country's railways and
apparel in the 1970s they also have
designs on space travel because they
patented a flying saucer I'm not kidding
this wasn't just one slightly unhinged
employee the the patent mentions the
inventor the wonderfully named Charles
Osmond Frederick but it is registered to
the company at their office they paid an
agent to file it for them it took more
than a year between the first filing and
the final submission and it's detailed
it goes on about how they'll use lasers
to ignite material for nuclear fusion
and then use magnetic fields to deflect
those particles to use them for thrust
RB the physics is questionable at best
and utterly unrealistic it worse but
every so often this gets dug up and
shown up as an example being ridiculous
optimist for here's the thing the patent
was granted patent officers are
massively overworked with years of
backlog to examine each application
requires a search through the catalogue
to make sure that no one has filed
anything like it before
examiner's aren't experts in all the
fields are looking at they're just
checking for originality it's quite
interesting to look at the published
patents there are mostly big
corporations churning out minor
variations ideas but occasionally you
will see a low garden shed inventor
patent to get a bizarre idea or an
unrealistic dream and although the
official policy are both the UK Patent
Office in the US Patent Office is to
reject something as ludicrous to say a
perpetual motion machine you can patent
something that isn't possible yet but
might be in future and at the height of
the space race after we've gone from
Sputnik to a man on the moon in just
over ten years was it plausible
the British Rail might have a fleet of
flying saucers in the far off space
years of the 1990s probably not but that
wasn't for the patent examiner to decide
assuming you renew your patent regularly
you've got a maximum of twenty years to
make it and profit from it
before it expires and anyone can make
your invention which what happen to the
flying saucer so if any of you would
like to make a space vehicle powered by
a laser ignited fusion reactor
you are entirely within your rights to
do so at least indirect but let's be
honest that's never actually